so underneath where you've written three
methods which is completing the squares
and example
okay so I'm going to give you a
quadratic in a second and one of the
nice things about completing the square
is that it always works even though it's
a little bit long-winded unlike say
factorizing you know how sometimes you
look at a quadratic remember the one I
gave you the other day I think from
memory is this do you member that and I
asked you to factorize it right what was
the big glaring problem in this
particular quadratic remember yeah these
guys are Jack it's like what am I
supposed to do with you you can't think
of any pair of numbers and if you recall
I think by the time we got to the end
you have to use the formula it's like a
square root of 53 something weed and
orchid in there of course you were never
going to guess them okay completing the
square however requires no guesswork if
you remember how it works
it's really quite straightforward to use
in any different contexts so before I
get here come on here we go let's have a
go at this Oh keep pushing it all right
so write this quadratic with me
okay now again I've chosen a particular
set of numbers where you look at it and
this guy here is going to coins so of
course at this point we could just leap
with a quadratic formula okay but let's
see if we can refer rehearse how
completing the square
works does anyone remember what do we
have to do first to get this you know
get the cogs turning everything okay so
you're actually you've got a couple of
steps forward most people can't do what
you're about to leave mentioning I don't
know how many if you're following can't
do it immediately so I'm gonna make it
just a little bit easy I'm gonna put an
extra line of working in getting get
this negative lemon over the other side
when you get out of the way I'm gonna
add 11 to both sides can we do that so
what does that leave us with x squared
plus 6x early you know kind of leave us
a space because I will do whatever just
in a second
I'm added 11 to both sides okay you
happy with that yeah not busy all right
now I saw a few more hands up where am I
gonna go from here here's where I get
the name completing the square yeah whoa
okay that was a mouthful let me see if I
got that I'm gonna take the coefficient
of X what's that in this case see I'm
going to have it and then I'm going to
square it then I choose that notebook
and I add it to the left-hand side which
means I add it to the right-hand side
because it's an equation and everything
is staying balanced okay so far so good
now what was the point of adding the
nine what's special about the nine
yeah okay very good it's a square number
but specifically not just it's a sweat
not love but it makes the whole
left-hand side a square a whole thing is
something plus something sweat what is
it it's gonna be X plus 3 right if I
read it right
can you just just rehearse it back in
your mind if you went backwards and
expanded it would give you back except a
6x what's not window yeah okay that
leaves you with a 20 over there in the
right hand side okay so that was the
hard part we completed the square at it
now that we hear where do we go someone
who hadn't said anything yeah the day
well you reckon Michael where would you
go from here I can't certain I can take
squaring both sides we gotta be careful
because when you do the square root on
the left hand side what happens to the
records oh there's actually two numbers
that you can square that will give you
20 right is the regular old square root
of 20 whatever that happens to be but
what's the other one therefore not - its
negative thank you okay we do collect
really read it as plus or minus those so
I forgive me for that okay so far so
good I'm almost there what was the point
what am I trying to do I want X to be
the subject I wanted by itself so what
am I going to do to both lines to finish
by convention by convention we write
that negative three out the front and
then you've got your pair of solutions
are you happy
okay you mean at the front of here
as opposed to so if I'm understanding
your question correctly you're asking
why the possible one is there as opposed
to where else would it go are you
questioning life there at all yeah okay
I guess the reason why is because the
square root of twenty and this is merely
this is a bit of a tricky bit and we're
going to get into this in more detail
when we look at inverse functions which
is next okay this number here right
square root of whatever where's the
first place that we encounter square
roots it's in something that we measure
does anyone remember what kinds of I had
trained what kinds of tribals give us
these guys I mean lot to do with
particularly the first time is right
angle triangle yeah okay so you're used
to encountering these guys and you might
say oh okay you're going to get this
side over here this side over here and
when you go ahead and use Pythagoras
theorem this guy very frequently ends up
being this certain like square root okay
now because this is one of the reasons
in moment because the first place that
we encountered dealing with numbers like
these is in the context of the length
this guy here is positive it doesn't
have two values when I write it like
that I only mean one number the positive
square root of 20 okay squirt what is
the square root of 20 is between
16:35 so flick four and a half fish okay
now what I mean is this guy is the
positive version of that doesn't include
the negative that's the only one number
so when you say what does it included
already the answers not only includes
one value so in order to have both I
have to run it as minus outflow okay I
hope that answer your question
come back to me afterwards